after all these years guys round I have
played Dead Island 2 and I'm here to
give you my opinions on the game and you
know shout out to them for giving us
this code to give you guys this coverage
you know they definitely value our
opinion just like you guys value our
opinion and this is my review on Dead
Island 2 for the Xbox series X
[Music]
what's going on you guys Lord ads here
coming at you for another review today
we're going to be reviewing Dead Island
2 not dying light to Dead Island 2.
first off let's let's get a little recap
all right my history with this game is I
was a huge fan of Dead Island one I
liked Riptide I really was looking
forward to Dead Island too and for the
longest time you guys know how it is we
have been waiting for this game for as
long as I can remember they showed this
game at like an E3 like it feels like
nine years ago or eight years ago
something like that and it's one of
those things where Dead Island 2 became
like a unicorn of the gaming industry
where we didn't know this game was
actually going to show up and nine times
out of ten wouldn't games take that long
to make they have a lot of issues when
they actually get launched question is
is Dead Island 2 worthy of your money
that's the biggest question I think the
majority of you are in this video for
that question I would say there's a lot
of factors that go into that one of the
things I really want to you know put a
spotlight on is the story of Dead Island
2. Dead Island 2
I wouldn't say is anything special when
it comes to the story you end up being
one of the survivors on a plane crash
kind of more like Dead Island one except
for it's in a different way what I do
like in this game is they bring
returning characters from the original
Dead Islands I won't go into anything
more detail on that I'm sure you've
probably seen them somewhere on Twitter
but that's for you to be spoiled not for
me to spoil you and I think I like stuff
like that because it brings back those
old roots I love when game sequels
especially go back and they bring those
original characters back but as far as
the story it's like I said it's nothing
special it's definitely playable it's
like I'm not going to sit here and tell
you the story is like the worst thing in
the world it is definitely not the worst
thing in the world but I will say
there's a lot more different types of
story going on out there and it didn't
do anything captivating it definitely
stuck the whole true to its roots of
being you know in a zombie apocalypse
world you're trying to survive trying to
get out of the area it's pretty
self-explanatory when it comes to a
zombie apocalypse movie or any type of
movie you've seen you've seen this story
over and over again but it doesn't take
away the fact that it's definitely worth
playing even though you probably know
the majority of the elements in this
game there are gameplay elements that
wasn't in the previous ones that did add
on to the story but I don't think they
ever really branched out with it and I
don't want to go into the the element
because I feel like that's a little bit
of a spoiler but something does happen
where you can quote-unquote evolve I'm
sure some of you know what I'm talking
about if you're watching this after
beating the game and I felt like that
perspective could have been done better
it could have been branched out felt
like there wasn't a lot of narrative
going into that but besides that the
story it's like I said very safe I think
that they did that intentionally this
game's never been designed to be around
the story like that that's why I want to
talk about the graphics you know you
guys know that I'm not the the biggest
fan when it turns to Graphics I don't
really care in terms of Graphics as long
as it looks modern to what we are doing
today most of the time that's the only
thing I care about I don't care really
about elevating the graphics of a game I
care more about the AI the gameplay I
care more about how the game feels than
the game looks now it does kind of look
okay it's got to be modernized but you
know it doesn't have to be like a god of
war or something like that one thing I
do want to say is Dead Island 2's
Graphics is phenomenal like I can
honestly say when I'm looking at this
game on the Xbox series X I'm sure it
looks way better on PC I'm just so many
times I'm playing this game I'm just
wowed by how good the game looks I'm
looking around the details they have in
the zombies sometimes when you are
attacking a zombie or you're having
confrontation with a bunch of zombies
and you know you have an ax and you
swing like a wide swing and hits them
all you literally see the debris on
their face that was hit off because you
were attacking them and it's attention
to detail stuff that makes games like
this good especially zombie apocalypse
games you know when you have all of
these artificial humans running around
at this point you know they're they're
dead but they're not dead and you're
attacking them and it's actually taking
limbs off it's you know when they're on
the ground and you hit them and you
could see the torn the torn Fabrics on
their clothes or if you go deeper you
could actually get into the Flesh of
them like stuff like this makes these
type of games really stand out and I
have to give my hat off the Dead Island
too in Deep Silver because stuff like
this to me is what a lot of people lack
stuff like this is what a lot of people
don't look at and I feel like they
really did a good job in terms of the
detail of this world especially when
you're in sunlight it is very beautiful
and I have to you know like I said give
them props for that now let's talk about
the game pill you guys know that I'm a
stickler for gameplay I love gameplay
pretty much everything you can imagine
from Dead Island one has returned in
here in some way shape or form and I
think they've done very well on
expanding on it to a degree I think they
cut it a little bit better but I will
say that this game does very well now
obviously the weapon combinations are
back I think this has been a standard
and in almost every zombie type of game
you know you could go in there you could
combine weapons you can make weapons you
can repair weapons I like this type of
gameplay uh I actually feel like in
terms of just the guns they actually did
a really good job making the guns feel
like they're actually useful now are
they the biggest useful thing in the
world no you're gonna run out of ammo
eventually but I feel like they had a
kick
I felt like the gun shot well the weapon
in combat in general this game was done
decently very well and I you know once
again man they did a good job on the the
combat you guys see where this review is
going you know I do think that when it
comes to the co-op it it functioned very
well with me you know you can have up to
three people in here you guys can go
explore stuff there wasn't a lot of
restrictions that was going into this
game for the most part I would honestly
say that this is the definition of what
a sequel should be obviously I felt like
some of the zombie varieties could have
been a little bit better that's just my
States me nitpicking for the most part
but what I will say is this game just
had a vibe to it it had energy to it you
know you go to the carnival there's a
lot of stuff going on there I felt like
the side quest was done well I felt like
you know the inflammation of Co-op was
done well in general when you're doing
stuff you know you do stuff with someone
that carries over to their game and I
think every developer if you're gonna
make a co-op game you gotta have
progress go through both stories it
can't just be one and they did have it
on this you know I tried it multiple
ways having lobbies up to entirely three
people and every single time it carried
over from all three people and I gotta
really props out to them because you got
games coming out that you have to beat
twice and I don't like that but you know
anyway that's pretty much what's going
on here man you know I always give you
guys options I always tell you multiple
different things if you should buy this
game and this is my honest opinion when
it comes to Dead Island 2. is it the
best game in the world right now no but
it's a really solid experience I enjoyed
this game from the beginning to end you
know especially if you want to play this
with a cough experience with a buddy or
two I think that's definitely an option
here and it actually has very good
systems in place to let you enjoy this
Co-op experience it's Dead Island 2 has
really good combat that I do feel the
majority you're gonna really enjoy
especially if you just like something as
simple as just you know going on there
and and defacing zombies attacking
zombies you know dealing zombies I think
you guys will enjoy that and the good
thing about is it lets you play any way
you want to play you can play this game
if you want to go in there with guns you
can now I will say towards the end of
the game that's probably not your
greatest thing I would use the guns for
some of the you know more Elite zombies
that you don't want necessarily close to
you and then if you want to go in there
just take a sword take a spear and you
know come customize the hell out of it
put lightning on it there's a lot of
different aspects that you can play this
game and that's what we love about these
type of games you know they're not the
greatest things in the world but they
definitely are a fun play they are
enjoyable to play especially with
friends and that's exactly how I would
tell you guys for this you know if you
like zombie games this is the game for
you you definitely need to try this if
you like Dead Island one this is more
Dead Island so I think you were going to
enjoy that the biggest criticism I could
probably give this game is and it's not
even its fault I came from playing more
Dying Light and I feel like the movement
restrictions that I feel in this game
because of playing games like Dying
Light made this game a little less
enjoyable now I will say that once I
played a little bit that ended up not
being as much of an issue because I got
used to not being able to you know
parkour to the degree that I was
parkouring in those older games but what
I will say is this game has its own
things man this game has its own charm
and sure it's not Dying Light I actually
do feel like dying light in terms of
movement it's a far better game but in
terms of killing zombies and to some
degree feeling threatened when you walk
into a hotel that ends up being this big
giant scary experience and you have to
go from one room to another while
there's stuff on fire where there's
zombies running everywhere I did feel
less safe in this game and I feel like a
zombie apocalypse needs to feel that way
you need to feel like it's actually
going down and to a degree I will say
that that didn't happen in some of these
other zombie games but it is present in
Dead Island too I want you guys to to
buy this game if you enjoy I do feel
like they did enough here to make it
worthy experience you can obviously wait
for it to hit a subscription service
because you know most likely eventually
this game is going to come to something
maybe Game Pass maybe PlayStation Plus
the epic game store will be putting
stuff on there all the time but I do
think this game's worth your money I
think it was a very fun experience only
if you like zombie type of experiences
if you don't really like it this
probably isn't going to get you into it
there's a lot of other games out there
on the market right now that's cheaper
to get you into a zombie for a franchise
but if you do like that type of
experience this is the game for you but
anyway tell me what you guys think in
the comment section below were you guys
expecting anything extravagant when it
comes to that Island too or does it look
like it is exactly what you thought it
was like I said it's definitely worth
your money if you like zombie type of
games and I think that's okay I think at
the end of the day people play these
type of games for that type of
experience but put in the comment
section below what you guys think I'm
very serious to hear you guys opinion
and don't forget to catch us every
Sunday at 1pm on this channel for the
iron Lords podcast where we talk about
everything in gaming my name's Lord
addict and I hope you guys have a good
day and this has been my review on Dead
Island 2 for the Xbox series X peace